عام
1993 بدا يوم العزاب كم مبادره لمجموعه من
الطلاب من الجامعه الاحتفال بفكره
العزوبيه وخلق منافس لعيد الحب انتشرت هذه
الفكره في جامعات مختلفه لذلك كان يطلق
عليها يوم البكالوريوس
وتطورت بمرور الوقت كمناسبه يمكن للرجال
والنساء الذين ليس لديهم شريك الاحتفال
بها و
مكافاه الحادي عشر من نوفمبر على وجه
التحديد يقال انا مبتكر الفكره كانوا اربع
اصدقاء كل واحد منهم يمثل رقم واحد في هذا
التاريخ المكون من اربع وحدات ما يعني
اربعه عزاب يقفون بجانب بعضهم البعض لكن
بعد ذلك ب 16 عاما قررت مجموعه علي بابا
العملاق التضخيم من المبادره وخلق صله
بينها وبين التسوق عبر الانترنت من خلال
تقديم اسعار وعروض النرويجيه خاصه للعزاب
حاليا ينتشر يوم العذاب في جنوب شرق اسيا
كما هو متداول في مناطق مختلفه من اوروبا
واليوم اصبح فرصه للقاء العزاب وهو تاريخ
شائع ايضا في حفلات الزفاف